hi my name is Etienne Vanina and I will
talk about building automated data
scientists the new version of
classifying predict so it's about the
improvement of classifying predict that
we did for version 11.2 and how we did a
new automation system for these
functions
everyone so today I'm going to talk
about the new version of classify and
predict in 11.2 and how they relate to
kind of broad a goal of creating
automated data scientists
okay so first what do we have in mind
when when I say automated are a
scientists well so let's see an example
example that I like is owner of a small
business let's say a bakery and and one
day this person decided to plug data
scientist software on database of the
business and start asking questions such
as how many quests are we're going to
sell next Sunday and and the system will
answer well according to your recorded
data and some other factors such as
whether there is a 90% chance that
between 62 and 67 person will be sold
okay so really a system what I have in
my system that you can through any data
at it will understand what's going on
and then you can have a conversation
with and you'll get insight from from
from this data so of cool there are many
parts that are important in order to
achieve such system one of them is
understanding the question of the human
okay in that case natural language in
that case given in natural language
another one is understanding the data
that is given because it can be in
various formats they can be like you
have these strings you have to know is
it a day it is it the city is it you
know you have to understand this the
ability to access external data also I
think it's very important in that case
it would be the weather that is probably
not in that abase of the of the business
and and then of course it's about
automatically creating a model that will
be able to predict what's going to
happen in the future
in that case okay that's a automatic
modeling parts and and then of course
communicating is a result back
to zoomin and actually many of these
parts are worked on in in warframe like
in the in the company in various groups
for example the human understanding
accessing external data and the
communicate result back really is a core
job of Wolfram Alpha okay that
understanding we try to do things that's
been like for some semantics import is
something that can import data and try
to understand what it is and interpret
it although I think we should work more
in this direction because it's probably
the part that we have the most missing
technology and what I'm going to talk
about is automatic modeling part okay
it's a machine learning part so this
automatically modeling is a job of
classifying predict which are the first
machine learning function that we put in
a language in version 10 3 years ago and
so it's so it's automatic modeling as I
was saying automatic functions and it's
supervised learning meaning that it
learns how to predict an output from
examples of input/output ok very broadly
speaking it learns a function for
example here there's four examples the
inputs are just a numeric input okay
which can be one two three four here and
the outputs is is a category a class
here is a or B and the function takes on
these examples and learns how to predict
the output for a new input so I try to
generalize so in that example it's it's
a pretty simple if I put one point six
well given one is a and two is a one
point six is probably be a and you can
also ask for probabilities so okay that
it's very toya example is only four that
I set up lens for so of course here the
probability are it's completely sure
it's a in that case and there is a
similar function called predicts with
basically the same except the output is
a numerical value now so let's put some
I don't know there is something more or
less linear just for understanding the
results something like that okay so it
will it will create a predictor function
that then we can use again so here one
is one point two two three point two
okay one point six probably between okay
three point actually it's above two one
oh why and I can again ask for the
probabilities but this time it's it
continues viable so it's not
probabilities but a distribution okay
actually some people don't see the back
you put this like this and okay that's
the idea and as is just a sin I didn't
put a method or I didn't say oh this was
a numerical viable and not a nominal
variable or didn't give any instruction
I just say here is a data find a way to
model it that's why we say there are
automatic and and the input can be so
it's just a numeric value can be also
know me know values it can be images and
can be text can be sound and and
actually one of our work is to try to
improve the possibilities so can be a
combination of all the types that I just
mentioned as well okay that's what
classifying predictive about and now I'm
going to talk about what changed what's
new in eleven point two so I assume you
I mean probably many of you know be this
function so the main thing that changed
at least that you can see when use it is
that now the training progress panel
that is displayed
during the training so to illustrate
this I'm grabbing a very classic that I
said machine learning which is M nice
it's n written digits okay I'm taking it
from our resource that we have a data
repository we only put datasets we have
to put more machine learning by the way
and and okay so this is a bunch of okay
and we ten digits okay
very classic and before if I was just
running classifier on this what would
happen to this you know mark itself as
evaluating and then you would just wait
and hope that it finishes you know
before you're bored otherwise you have
you know just cancel and you lost
everything but now it's bit different
now as you'll see there is this panel oh
there's trouble in in presentation mode
that's interesting well we discover bugs
even while presenting so actually let me
go
not in pushing different mode just to to
show this so working okay let's try
again
okay so you can see this this
information panel about how what's
happening in the in the training gives
you the time elapsed progress bar the
current method that the system believe
it the best and so I'm also the current
accuracy that the system managed to
achieve or the current value of the loss
function so you can really know what's
going on during the training and you can
decide to stop at any point I mean here
it's it's already about to stop by
itself but let's do it again actually to
make it longer I'm going to use a tango
option I'm going to tell you about this
option just after I say one minutes then
we are would be fine and oh yeah so you
can also switch panels so he will show
you the current accuracy as function of
the training side of the system tested
so the system does many experiments it
says oh let's try with 50 example let's
try with 100 example and with this
method and let's try so a bunch of
experiments and here it's kind of a way
for you to visualize the results of
these experiments that's what we call a
learning curve actually sorry I was I
wasn't a stop button before let me go
back on the learning curve so yes you
have a stop button so at any moment you
can click the stop button okay and it
will stop but fortunately it won't lose
everything like before it will grab the
best model so far that it managed to
obtain and return it and you see there
was a bit of delay when I press the stop
button because it's kind of finishing
what it's doing if you want even more
abrupt ending you just board the
evaluation and it will still return what
it has so far but by a bony absolutely
everything so if I do a board I have it
directly yep okay good question good
question okay okay so okay so let me go
on the on the on the time goal first
what it is so it's an option to really
indicate the function how long it should
spend training it's not a time
constraint it's not like don't train
more than dicks amount at least amount
it's really a goal that should be
reached which can be really useful if
you have you know ten hours ahead of you
like you know you go to bed say okay I
put 10 hours so you can put a number of
second or you can put you know classic
Mathematica if I put one minutes and
this will this will work as well and the
automatic is really interesting thing
that I think okay I can start giving
explanation and maybe I can talk more
after this system between experiment is
always trying to predict how well it
would perform how it would perform the
food that I set to try to predict from
the experiment Oh probably this method
is the best and how long would this
method take on the full data set so that
is estimation and it tries to only train
let's say one configuration so one
method and a parameter on the full data
set that's kind of the principle of the
system if you set different performance
goal and we will
two or three but but it's like a small
amount on the full data set and a lot of
experiments before but of course it's
always a bit wrong in the prediction
that it does on the full data set so it
kind of comes back you know maybe I can
okay maybe I can start turning turning
about that
so let's put in a normal mode like with
that without a time goal and I'm going
to directly to the last view that shows
all the experiments that are done okay
and you see it sometimes it will in
order to grab more information it will
give us the reset sometime just to have
a good information about how long we
have and this will influence how long we
will spend in in the earlier stage
because if you know you're going to
spend a lot of time to Train the final
thing you know that you have enough time
to do a lot of experiments so there's
kind of an interaction between getting
mod or edge and then so okay and so you
have these learning curves that are very
important because they can they can
actually let me talked about that in the
classified information so we changed
also classify your information to have a
similar panel so I just do classifying
information of the classifier and this
returns so you see very similar panel
and so you have access to okay so the
type of the data number of class the
method including its its hyper
parameters so believed accuracy that
that classifier has on a test set so
because it test itself on the sets and
the laws the time it takes to evaluate
an example the memory of the classifier
you know things like this and these
learning curves which are very important
because they can help you decide if you
should get more data or not and for
example in that case it's clearly going
down the loss function so it's clear
that with more data we'll get a better
classifier and often getting data is
expensive so so it's important like if
if the learning curve is plateauing
it's important to know it in order not
to spend a lot of time getting more data
whereas there was just not enough
information in the features that using
for example or maybe you model was not
good enough but it's not that as a
bottleneck something here that has to
change that's that's very important to
consider with a learning curve we can
set with accuracy
I mean learning curves loss right we
also pay attention to the arrow bars
because some time you're the feeling is
going down actually they are about when
that case is clear with it we need more
data so yes that that's the main changes
like the one thing I should mention just
there is that this panel you can also
control it with the function training
progress reporting so for example you
can just remove it which kind of what
would have happened before classify will
just be like this okay but it's useful
when you use it inside another function
and you want many things appear and so
on you know all you can if you if you
work like on a standalone kernel like
you know you know in a shell with a
comment line you can just do print and
like if you have no front end basically
you can do print and it will print the
same information but this time just a
stupid print which by the way this so
you seen similar panel in in the net
train probably and we hope that this
this idea of having an evaluation panel
will kind of spread in a language I can
think of optimization function that
might use it you know and and it might
be nice to see the Revolution and
stopping the optimization whenever we
want or maybe there's some others
so we yeah
how do you create this panel yeah so so
yeah I mean this is something we created
from scratch like it's a it's a grid
inside we have we have a only Tillet e
function to do through this and you know
it's not using like monitor progress
like thing there were before I hope so I
hope so yes I mean it seems like the
type of problem where panel could be
could be there so so yeah I hope so I
mean I'm not in charge of this function
so we should discuss people that are but
but if it's possible it's always
complicated when you use external
libraries and so on
but if there's a way from the external
aggregate kind of grab the state of
thing that are going on which which
might make sense in optimization
function I can't believe that you have a
nice library that'll give you anything
so I guess so yeah so so actually these
in terms of timing so these are tested
that is created during the training and
there's like some sort of time
constraints are things are eristic that
it should not spend more than 20% of
amount of time to test so so there's a
lot of yeah this type of automation
inside to be sure that nothing not crazy
because sometimes you have a method that
can take a very long time to test like
nearest neighbor nearest neighbor is
very fast to train you don't do anything
basically but to test maybe depending of
them of dimension and someone can be
slow so these sort of things - yeah and
it's like the test as large as possible
as long as I spend less than 20% of time
that I spend training that's basically
whatever it is that's why sometimes
you'll get very small so this is a
statistical error because of the size of
the test set then we get a small one
sometimes you get a big one well you
don't have real control in order to have
a control on your test set you can use
plataforma
so so actually uh hopefully this will
reduce the need of classifier
measurements because some time that's
good enough you know you have to
courtesy of the learning curve let's
move on but if you want to be more
precise control exactly what's going on
use classifier measurements okay so just
to continue yeah I guess I can continue
on this thing
so this also been some news on the on
the methods so ok an important things
that all the methods are documented now
so if we go for example I don't know
linear regression probably the first
thing we did oh it doesn't find it
there's two s oh yeah sorry
and and so yeah now now there is there
is a there is a documentation with some
examples more importantly a bit how how
the method works and more importantly is
a sub option I mean the options you can
use when indicated this this method so
you can say you know something like
classify okay your data whatever method
goes to xsplit auto less a logistic
regression and then you can also specify
this is a classic syntax classic design
like optimization function use the same
type of thing for example you can put
some sub options for example here it can
be l2 regularization goes to five and
here you can get the list of the
possible bigger the list of the possible
sub option you can use so so it's going
a bit away from the full automation but
I think experts will be happy to have to
have this control over other methods
okay then you have new method decision
tree very classic method actually know
what we could we could explore
decision tree you go it's there very
classic method and gradient boosted tree
which is with the trees it's like a
matrix it's a forest at constructing
it's similar to one forest but but with
some some differences which is a method
that data scientists like a lot on Cagle
many competition that one with this
waste method so we added it always
emitted a bit harder to automatize
because as you see there's a lot of
upper parameters that have been they're
hard to be determined automatically so
often when forest actually performs
better just because in full automation
mode but maybe if you spend some time a
lot of time you'll end up with a grain
boosted tree that is better and we
improved some some methods just neural
network now use our neon attack
framework before it was kind of our
primitive framework that we had at the
time and also linear regression
regression has been been improved and
yeah neural network is yeah it's an
interesting one because it's not trivial
to automatize neo network like you have
all structure to determine automatically
that it's quite complex but we think
there's a lot of power in it and and
when we'll manage to do that well we it
can never be fast training but in some
case we can get very high performance by
having automatic network so it's a bit
it's kind of a research area actually
that we are going into so so if you see
crazy results with a cranial network and
it's also because in the current version
it's also because it's very hard to
automatize this thing but actually we'd
love to get your feedback like we'd get
a lot of work on that we know that is
highly experimental but please use this
method and tell us if it worked or not
yeah
No so so this function are only one
output one plus C so if you have two I
put your two classifiers and then there
will be all on your network yes yes yes
yes definitely we would want to have
predict to be generalized to predict
anything and including image and text
and so on but it is a rather big work as
you can imagine but as something we want
to tackle soon it's probably one
fulfillment before Landis terrine okay
let's not go in plan but there's
something want to do okay so maybe I
kind of still have a few minutes so let
me let's talk a bit about what's under
the hood and so it's really a new
automation procedure that enabled all
this change but actually the reason we
decided to do to change classifying
predict was first to change the
automation procedure and then realized
that this new automation procedure could
give a lot of benefits such as the
progress panel the possibility to
interrupt and an end the yeah progress
bar time goal the performance estimation
and the learning curves so we're really
happy to find a nice automation
procedure that is fastened before but
also gives all this all this positive
side effect I should say I guess that
effect is sometimes badly committed ok
so just tell you a little bit how it
works the idea is to start with an
initial set of configuration that we
believe would perform not too bad so the
beginning is kind of an aristocrat
configuration that could perform well
but then we're going to start training
this configuration but not on the full
data set because it would be too slow so
we train it on restricted data sets that
are pretty small and to be fast to train
so I call these experiments so we do
this experiments and told you a little
bit before and and then we measure how
well this thing perform how fast they
were to train what is this memory and so
on and we try to pray
how well they would perform on the full
data set that's that's the hard part is
like you see a configuration that
trained that at this performance with
one example this performance with 500
example how well would perform on 10,000
examples of course the prediction are
very uncertain but still there's some
information there and so we leverage
this information in order to give
priority to configuration that I've
potential that that have a higher chance
of performing well on the full data set
and so we give them more data then we
grab more information then we redo the
predictions new selection and so on okay
so it's a continuous process and just
let me show you in action I showed you a
little bit already but let's do let's do
angle then we have time to talk about it
sorry let's see it's at least I think
why is it all blurry okay and okay let's
run this and you can see on this last
panel it's the learning curve for all
the configuration by the way
configuration it's like both the method
and options of the method I per
parameters that's what I call a
configuration so each of this line
represent the configuration that's been
trained on values that asset size and
you can see here the system that has the
experiments you know try and ladder that
I said and come back to smaller that I
said because it realized oh actually I
have time I can do things with more
experiments on a small data set and and
and so it's a bit of an exploration
procedure but I try to be a bit smart on
which which example so for example this
one was apparently nearest neighbor
pretty good so it's already trained on
the food that I said still see that
predict this again it's still have time
to do some more experiment just in case
I was wondering that is better yeah so
so it is an important thing to
understand is that because the training
times of morph method are at least
linear okay when I double the size that
I said it at least twice faster to Train
maybe except nearest-neighbor although
there's some pre-processing so it might
also be true of nearest neighbor it
means that the experiments are pretty
cheap that if we are multiplying by a
constant you know we we explore the
training set size in a geometric way we
can do a lot of experiments on small
data sets for nothing and the whole
question is how much information do they
give right they're really cheap to do
they're done perfect information but
still information there and and that
that's what we leverage to to get
something faster okay so I was saying it
that's everything that is new procedure
brings and now what could we do for the
future of this procedure one thing we to
include you know you know to have a
configuration not be just method and
parameters but also include the
pre-processing to say oh let's try this
reprocessing this method is a parameter
all these other processing these other
methods these other parameter because
clearly it's kind of separated it's
processing automatic with another
methods and then this so this is would
be great to do that to be able to
combine methods maybe oh actually let's
do a neural network on this image and
let's do I don't know random forests on
this other data and then let's gather
the result this is something that
currently we don't do but I hope we'll
and then there is in order to guide us
in this automatic for us for developers
is to gather many data sets and and do
experiments on many data sets in order
in a way to learn from the data sets how
to learn on a feature that I said that's
why it's called learning to learn or
meta learning that's something we're
very excited about and we already start
gathering data sets and hopefully we can
do something useful soon okay
thank you Bingham over time
you